ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément moins de paris
mais toujours loin de ce qu'il y leur
vie ressemble assez peu à ce qu'on voit
à la télé ils ont le sentiment d'être
des français de seconde zone comme s'ils
étaient invisibles ces français ne
veulent plus se taire ils ont des choses
à dire la france oubliée c'est une
rencontre avec ces citoyens qui ne se
résignent pas à la fatalité la france
oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit
jamais
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans l'oise à
betty saint pierre je rencontre corinne
51 ans et intérimaires en usine bonjour
merci nous accueillir votre prénom c'est
comment alors c'est corinne covin hockey
décalage 51 ans et vous faites quoi dans
la vie
vous êtes dans l'intérim depuis quand
bien quinze ans maintenant j'ai
travaillé dans la logistique
j'ai travaillé dans le travail / br /
blangy quand j'habitais dans le dans le
nord et la sueur descendu près de ma
famille parce que je me suis séparé du
coup je suis venu un peu près de ma
famille sinon je suis d'origine de
bêtisiers cela met souvent fait aux
taureaux source.la donc et beaucoup vous
travaillez beaucoup en usine en fait
c'est ça oui oui ça une usine de balle
est donc bon bah avec le confinement il
ya des malheureux mais bon il ya des
heureux aussi parce que bombe avec les
produits d'hygiène tout ça donc ça fait
plus de boulot donner des enfants vit
chez 3 enfants louis sont grands ils
sont chacun on est toujours là pour les
aider parce que c'est dur aussi pour
maintenant c'est on a toujours du souci
étant quand ils sont petits ou quand ils
sont grands il faut être là pour les
aider parce que c'est dur aussi pour eux
quoi le boulot il n'est pas toujours là
quoi et naturellement quand il ya eu les
gilet jaune en france vous avez tout de
suite occupé les premiers ronds points
exactement parce que ça faisait
longtemps que je me demandais comment
ils font les personne seule avec un
salaire quoi est ce qu'on en fait au
niveau des impôts
on est vachement plus taxés et en tout
seul sans personne à charge
alors que bon bah on paye le loyer tout
seul l'électricité les femmes tous les
factures on est là tous on n'a qu'un
salaire pour payer tout seul donc et on
doit encore on doit payer plus fois plus
que ceux qui sont un couple qu'en fait
on se demande où va notre argent groove
à nous avons payé des impôts c'est pas
on veut payer des impôts pour aider
quand même tous ces services publics
mais je demande quand même les postes
les écoles les hôpitaux qui ferment
bon après faut dire qu'il ya peut-être
moins de boulot il ya peut-être plus de
rs a payé
et les étrangers qui rentrent qu'il faut
mais bon c'est assez on a envie dans une
drôle d'époque que je trouve dès qu'on
peut respirer un peu ça fait du bien à
lui la fin du mois il suffit d'un d'une
réparation de voitures en électroménager
ou est dans le rouge
voilà maintenant il faut me même pu
mettre un peu de sou de côté pour au cas
où s'il ya un truc comme ça nous arrive
pas et c'est ça qui est incroyable c'est
de travailler de s'esquinter la santé et
à la fin du mois on est dans le rouge en
fait on après c'est plus la vie comme un
ben quoi on subit en fait c'était mieux
avant du temps de vos parents c'était
plus facile lui même personnellement je
trouve que c'était beaucoup plus facile
on allait en vacances tous les ans quand
fait pendant mon père l'était masson ma
mère était femme de ménage et on était à
quatre enfants maintenant et vous
parliez aussi des étrangers vous êtes
engagé politiquement pas aujourd'hui au
niveau étrangers ben je trouve que c'est
pas assez surveillé quoi en fait les
va-et-vient des étrangers quoi c'est
pour aussi après c'est mon avis c'est
pas c'est pas du racisme parce que moi
je viens de mon grand-père et les
portugais donc mais avec tout ce qu'on
voit le terrorisme tout ça ça fait peur
quoi on est quand même de plus en plus
de rentrer ces personnes là il ils sont
pas suivies en fait tous ces personnes
qui viennent parce que j'entends
beaucoup d'eau à toi tu vote le pen est
comme quand elle veut pas plus
d'étrangers unia n'a jamais dit ça elle
vous bien que les étrangers rentrer dans
le pays mais qui travaillent avant de
leur donner des sous qu'on allait payer
quoi la droite la gauche la droite la
bouche
ça fait des années et des années qu'on
voit ça c'est juste essayer de voir si
ça ira pas mieux de toute façon ça peut
pas être pire que maintenant
depuis le temps que je les écoute moi je
comprends pas pourquoi les gens n'essaye
pas au courant fait
allez c'est parti vous êtes dans des
groupes facebook des forums des vous
vous informez beaucoup par par les
réseaux sociaux lui je ggd tout ça après
pour en prendre et en laisser parce que
bon c'est que les gens sont divisés
c'est comme sur le combi de quoi il ya
tellement d'avis on sait plus où mettre
de la tête voir c'est plus vraiment mais
qu'est ce qui a le plus embêtant à
comprendre c'est le fait que dans les
métros ils sont les uns sur les autres
les petits commerces où on rentre avec
le masque où on n'est pas beaucoup
il est ferme j'ai mal à comprendre mais
là c'est sûr que toute façon il y en a
beaucoup qui vont mettre la clé sous la
porte tout à son seuil et ça va des
niable alors voyez le rond point on
avait là ta cabane chez les jaunes
donc voilà bon allez on va essayer de se
pas de pas se faire écraser
ça serait dommage on encore des choses à
faire je les traverser toutes les
semaines ce but on avait deux une grande
cabane l samedi plutôt dans les actes à
paris et le samedi oui on allait
certains rient tous ensemble alors ici
on a fait des actions aussi on a bloqué
plusieurs fois le payage tout le monde
venait de discuter avec nous qu'ils
étaient solidaires et tout quoi qu'il
fallait pas lâcher qu'il fallait pas
fallait rien lâcher
quoi et aujourd'hui c'est fini les jeux
finis je crois pas mais je pense que ça
peut revenir laissant sans les gilles et
parce que automatiquement la répression
aller dès qu'il ya quelqu'un qui porte
un gilet jaune c'est voilà il faut il
faut le virer de la peau non y aller en
tant que ben le peuple quoi en fait
naki son corps solidaires ont fini leurs
reportages chaque fois par une photo
vous allez vous asseoir sur le rond
point vous avez passé beaucoup de temps
en tailleur comme ça voilà super on
lâche rien
[Musique]